sommes devant une auto portrait réalisé
par un artiste qui s'appelle julien
blais qui a été fait en
1883 comme lundi que la date en bas à
droite julien biais est pas un créole il
est né à lyon une famille de commerçants
et ils quittent la réunion
dans les années 1870 pour aller se
former en fait à l'école des beaux-arts
à paris c'est un des rares
un des rares artistes nés à la réunion
qui n'est pas acquis qu'il ya peut-être
eu d un côté autodidacte au début mais
qui est allé se former auprès de m
auprès de professeurs en métropole et
parmi la toute petite production qui
nous restent parce que c'est un artiste
qui est mort l'assumant jeunes il est
mort à 40 ans on a quelques portraits en
inde et est ce qu'ils sont des petits
tableaux et surtout le musée léon dierx
a eu de la chance
de 2,2 d'avoir en donation en fait son
auto portrait c'est à dire le portrait
de l'artiste lui même alors c'est un
portrait qui s'inscrit dans une longue
tradition d'autoportraits d'artistes les
artistes en faisant un auto portrait
c'était un moyen pour des pratiques et
d'exercer le portrait est quelque chose
qui leur permet de gagner leur vie parce
que quand on commande un portrait ca
moyen pour les artistes de gagner de
l'argent donc comment faire un portrait
il faut s'exercer il faut pratiquer
comment peut-on pratiquer en faisant son
auto portrait pour pouvoir justement
exercer sa peinture les cadrages la
couleur la luminosité etc et là il fait
son auto portrait donc il faut imaginer
une toile de ce côté ci est en face de
lui un miroir dans lequel ils se
regardent et ensuite ils posent au fur
et à mesure les compos les couleurs sur
sa toile donc du coup ça donne ce regard
dre persan très vif il nous interpelle
quand ils nous regardent mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ce
portrait il n'a pas cherché à se
représenter comme un artiste ayant
réussi on sent que c'est un jeune
artiste qui est débutant
mais il aurait pu me dire voilà je
décide de me représenter avec un livre
qu'une statue montrant ce qu'est ce qui
est plus important pour moi c'est je
suis artiste mais c'est l'idée c'est mes
réflexions c'est mes lectures et sert
non il a décidé de se représenter comme
un praticien comme un artisan il à sa
palette à la main il à ses pinceaux son
vêtement est un peu usé il est agile
assis sur une chaise à ses modèles il a
un chapeau sur sa tête pour se protéger
on peut imaginer qu'il fait froid dans
son atelier et qu'il est en train de
peindre dans quelque chose qui a un peu
à un peu sommaire bref il décide de se
montrer vraiment en artisan de la
peinture et non pas comme on aurait pu
le faire en qu'un qui privilégie plutôt
le côté intérêts qu'il a il prit j'y
connais vraiment le côté manuel de la
peinture cette eau portée est assez rare
on en a très peu dans les collections
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que il a été à l'élève de le
man qui était lui-même un élève dingue
et on retrouve ici toute la grande
tradition du portrait classique de la
peinture du dessin parfait issue
justement de l'information d'un des plus
grands artistes du 19e siècle français
en l'occurrence jean dominique